CROVITZ: Good evening, everyone.
I'm your presider, Gordon Crovitz.
And welcome to the Council on Foreign Relations
meeting on privacy and security in the digital
age.
We will, as is always the case, have plenty
of time for questions.
So please prepare those for members.
We're very lucky to have a panel of people
who are both highly experienced and highly
opinionated.
So we should have a very good evening.
There are bios in your materials, but Michael
Chertoff is chairman of the Chertoff Group,
formerly served as secretary of Homeland Security,
was also a prosecutor and a federal appeals
court judge.
Cyrus Vance, Jr. is the district attorney
for New York, better known in the movies and
thrillers as the Manhattan DA.
(Laughter.)
And to my right is Adam Segal, who directs
the Council's digital and cyberspace policy
program.
So I think the biggest issue in this area
of privacy and security is what the founders
would have made of this-(laughter)-and all
the other smartphones in the room.
The Fourth Amendment says reasonable searches
and seizures are permitted.
What happens when technology makes them not
possible?
So I wanted to start by asking Cy Vance, if
you would, to talk a little bit about the
analog era.
So before all of these digital issues came
up, before you had issues like in San Bernardino
where we have the dispute between Apple and
the FBI over whether Apple should be obliged
to help the FBI access that phone, remind
us what the world was like in the analog era.
What kinds of information could prosecutors
get with a traditional warrant?
VANCE: The backdrop to this is I'm speaking
really on state and local law enforcement
issues, just so I don't appear to be a federal
expert when I'm not.
And really up until September of 2014, we
accessed the contents of mobile devices, smartphones,
if we could get a warrant from a judge focused
on a specific phone.
And the range of information that we would
get out of that phone was enormous from time
to time, and extremely helpful.
I think it's fair to say that in the last
15 years, up until the fall of 2014, and whether
it was a case involving homicide or financial
crime, digital evidence, very, very often
on smartphones, was a key part of gathering
the evidence for a case.
So the way the world worked up until late
September, 2014 is among the many avenues
we would investigate for evidence relevant
to the case would be in smartphones, as well
as laptops, and other devices.
I just want to add that it was very important
and is very important for us in terms of building
cases, but I also think it's very important
in terms of making sure that prosecutors had
all the information they needed to make the
right calls.
We have had cases in our office where because
of our ability to access a phone, when police
arrested someone for homicide and I had a
very smart assistant over the course of the
weekend who just didn't think that the timeline
was adding up, we could get that phone out
to Apple, fly it out with a warrant, bring
it back, and in this case my assistant was
able to cut lose the gentleman who'd been
identified and arrested for murder by the
police, find the true killer, who is now serving
a lengthy term in prison.
So the point is, it was important not only
to build cases-or essential.
It's also important to make sure that we are
exercising our responsibilities as prosecutors
to the degree that I think the court expects
us to.
And there is going to come a time, because
of the inability to access phones which hold
a huge amount of evidence, that judges are
going to be dealing with motions by lawyers
who are saying that we believe in that phone
is information that could exculpate my client.
And we're going to have to sort through how
we move forward in those cases.
I think everybody in this room would want
the prosecutor investigating your case, or
someone you know, to have all the facts.
We now live in a world where we are not getting
all the facts.
Many of the facts are on smartphones because
criminals, just like you and me, have moved
off-paper and onto digital devices.
So that's the pre-world and the post-world
is-I'm sure we'll talk about.
CROVITZ: And just to really level-set this
discussion, even before-going back before
the smartphone, prosecutors could get access
to bank security boxes, to health records,
all sorts of things that we in the digital
era would say are on our phones, but at that
time were more available.
VANCE: Search warrants enabled us to get access
to really anything, but only with the authority
of a court.
And, you know, the devices today are really
the only-as far as I can tell, the only warrant-proof
devices that exist.
And that is posing a challenge I think to
both sides.
SEGAL: I wonder-if I can ask-because it strikes
me that, Gordon, you're getting to an important
point, which is that qualitatively all of
the data on the phone is different because
all of those things are in one place, where
on the analogy, right, you'd have to do the
legwork to get all of those specific things.
VANCE: I mean, maybe, maybe not.
If you-when Mike was U.S. attorney he probably,
like I have, when officers go out and do search
warrants, they probably have three or four
locations-office, home, associates.
It wasn't-it's not that complicated.
And maybe you hit 20 places with search warrants,
but still it is true that much of this information
is now collapsed into a single device, but
it's the same kind of information that would
have been accessible to a warrant, whether
it was in a car, a home, a safety deposit
box, or some physical location.
CROVITZ: And last time I saw, you had estimated
that in your office there are 200 iPhones
or so that you would like to be able to get
access to, but have not been able to.
VANCE: It was clear to me when Apple moved
to reengineer its phones to be incapable of
being opened, even with a warrant, that this
was going to have an impact on the way we
did business.
We in the Manhattan DA's office created our
own cyber lab over the last several years
because the NYPD simply can't keep up with
the volume of devices that we're asking them
to interrogate at the speed we're asking them
to do it.
So we started our own lab.
And of the phones that have submitted to our
lab, of the 750 phones that have been submitted
to our lab that we have gotten-we've gotten
warrants for all the Apple devices, and 230
of those devices are inaccessible to us.
Most at this point are iPhone 6's running
with operating systems eight and above.
CROVITZ: So let me turn now to Michael Chertoff.
You've been on different sides of this issue.
You've been a prosecutor, head of Homeland
Security.
You've been one of the more public proponents,
I think, of the argument that there should
not be any ban or tinkering with end-to-end
encryption, of the kind that Apple, and Google,
and others have now executed for their operating
systems.
Explain that.
CHERTOFF: And first, let me come back to the
way the world was prior to smartphones, because
since time immemorial people have tried to
frustrate law enforcement's ability to get
evidence, even when there's a lawful basis
to get it.
So we were talking earlier, back in the day
when I was a prosecutor and I was getting
wiretap or electronic surveillance warrants,
you know, that allowed us to lawfully put
a tap on a phone or put a recording device
in a building.
It wasn't long before bad guys figured that
out, so what they would do is they would turn
the radio up so you couldn't have an audible,
discernible voice.
Or they'd communicate in sign language.
Or they'd walk around the block and have a
conversation outside of earshot.
Now, those were all frustrating the ability
of law enforcement to use a warrant to get
information, but we accepted that's the nature
of free society, is you can't make people
sit in a room and talk audibly.
(Laughter.)
So I would argue that this is a species of
a problem we've faced on and off for many,
many years.
I also think that one of the things that you
have to consider is end-to-end encryption's
only a way of a number of different ways people
will secure data.
For example, you have, you know, various kinds
of apps that will cause messages to disappear
after you read them.
That's a security device, as is encryption.
So the challenge is, to what extent, as you
balance the legitimate and understandable-and
I don't minimize this-desire of law enforcement
to get evidence that can be critical in a
case-how do you balance that against the ability
of people to secure their own data, particularly
in a world in which the government tells people
with respect to cybersecurity: Don't count
on us to protect you.
You have to protect your own data.
And so to me, what you see is really a tradeoff
not between security and privacy, but between
two types of security.
The last thing I would say, which is relevant
to the smartphone, the volume of data is now
hugely greater.
And one of the interesting legal issues that's
emerging now is to what extent even a warrant
for a phone, or an accepted warrantless legal
basis to search a phone changes when the phone
itself becomes a different kind of device.
I think because it's handling so much information
that it's far beyond what in the old days
you could have considered, you know, within
a person's personal control.
But beyond that, because often the data's
no longer on the device itself.
The device is literally a key to data being
stored in the cloud.
And this comes up, for example, in the area
of border searches.
The rule has been-and I argued for this when
I was secretary of Homeland Security-that
when you cross a border the government is
entitled to look at everything you bring with
you.
And if it's a briefcase, they can look in
the briefcase.
And the law was, if it was a laptop, anything
on the laptop could be looked at because you're
bringing in what might be contraband.
But now I ask myself, does that change when
in effect the phone is no longer the repository
of the data, but is the key to get the data
that's already in the cloud.
And that would be a little bit, to my mind,
like if I crossed the border with my house
key and someone said, OK, now I want to have
your key and then go to your house and look
at everything in your house.
I don't think we would consider that a border
search.
So in many ways, the technology is confounding
even the preexisting legal categories.
CROVITZ: You co-wrote an op-ed in The Washington
Post about a year go on this topic that I
thought had a fascinating conclusion.
I've been curious what you meant.
And this is my big chance to ask you, so I'm
going to.
(Laughter.)
I'm going to remind you by quoting you.
What you wrote was: If law enforcement and
intelligence organizations face a future without
assured access to encrypted communications,
they will develop technologies and techniques
to meet their legitimate mission goals.
And of course, in the case later, after you
wrote this, the FBI did get from a third party
a means for accessing the San Bernardino terrorist's
phone.
Were you suggesting that law enforcement and
intelligence agencies won't go dark, as the
FBI director has warned?
CHERTOFF: I was saying two things.
One is, I think it's actually the nature of
encryption that it's never clear to me that
you reach a stage where you have perfect encryption.
If you know anything about public and private
key encryption, the essence of creating the
private key is to have very long sequences
of prime numbers that would require years
of constant computing to break.
But actually I was-today I was shown a chart
about various contests that have been run
over the last few years to see whether people
could break ever longer encrypted keys.
And not surprisingly, over time people have
found ways to break them.
Now, there will always be another key that's
even longer-although there'll be some constraints
on the ability to do that because the ability
then to manage the data itself will become
a little bit challenging.
But my point is, it's not in the nature of
encryption that it is a static issue.
There will always be new innovations.
And there will also be new countermeasures.
And I think we saw that in the '90s when there
was a debate about whether there needed to
be-was there going to be concerns about telephonic
encryption and whether there needed to be
a requirement that that be limited as well.
The second point I was making was that there's
no vastly more information available-apart
from the encrypted content itself-than we
had even 10, 15 years ago.
I mean, this is a paradise for intelligence
agents and law enforcement agents because
of the amount of data that's generated from
unencrypted locational data, metadata, financial
data, et cetera, et cetera.
And in terms of what is the intelligence challenge
of locating people who are potential threats,
which is finding the needle in the haystack,
the haystack is now so large that it's the
kind of the thing we only fantasized about
15 years ago after 9/11.
So again, without minimizing the challenges-particularly
if you're going to present a case in court-that
are posed by encryption, I think encryption
is not by its nature ever in a permanent state
of being perfect.
And second, there are so many other kinds
of information and evidence out there that
net, if I'm an investigator, I'd much rather
be where I am in 2015 than where I was, let's
say, in 2010 or 2005.
CROVITZ: So, Adam, in your new book, "The
Hacked World Order," you made the point that
as we discuss these issues in the U.S., we're
really not discussing them in a vacuum.
And we'll talk in a moment about potential
legislation.
But describe what you meant by that, that
these kinds of issues are-may be in that way
a little bit more complicated than a generation
ago when we had telecom regulations that applied
to domestic telecom companies.
SEGAL: Well, I think first is the reality
that the U.S. has no monopoly on the technology,
right?
Even if we were to come up to some discussion
that we were going to ban certain types of
encryption, it will be developed other places,
right?
So I think that is a huge problem.
The second is clearly there's a huge demonstration
effect going on.
We can see that the Chinese and others have
looked at the debate.
You know, the Indians introduced and then
very quickly removed a ban on encryption when
the realized that everyone was going to have
to hold onto their plaintext for years, and
they decided that it was not manageable.
So there's clearly a kind of demonstration
effect that's going on to other countries.
And then, you know, there is the larger issue
of what we want-what the goals are for U.S.
technology companies, right?
So what are-what are we thinking about their
competitiveness and how they're going to be
in other markets.
You know, the FBI director, of course, had
kind of thrown it off and said that this is
a marketing strategy, but we saw, you know,
last week when a Brazilian judge knocked WhatsApp
offline for about a day and a half, and several
millions-tens of millions of Brazilian users
didn't get access to it, that all of these
interactions are closely tied to security
and economics.
CROVITZ: So, Cy Vance, I wanted to ask you
a question along these lines.
We've heard good arguments about the complications
of potential regulation, and the technology
is complex.
On the other hand, Apple and Google, in a
way, created a change in the situation by
moving to default encryption.
So before they did this in 2014, were there
reasons for them to be concerned about hacking?
VANCE: This is what has puzzled me personally
about the communication on this issue after
Apple moved to default device encryption,
September 2014.
At that time, Apple was operating on iOS 7.
We are now on iOS 9.
And it was I think before the six came out.
Now, in that time period, this was the time
period where we were presenting affidavits
and warrants to judges for them to review.
And if they approved it, we took them to Apple,
and Apple did whatever magic it did, and returned
to us the responsive material.
There was no indication that Apple's ability
to maintain the security of the phone content
was an issue.
In fact, Apple said exactly the opposite,
that their iOS 7 was state of the art.
And also, interestingly, said they felt they
had a responsibility as a corporation to make
sure that law enforcement was able to get
the information it needed, to find the Alzheimer's
patient or other issues on an emergent basis.
So then default device encryption came in
in September '14.
So I think the question that Apple needs to
answer, from my position, is has there ever
been a situation where when a law enforcement
agency sends a phone out to Apple to be decrypted
there was ever a compromise of data on that
phone.
I mean, that's really the fundamental thing
that started all this was the concern about
what is called a backdoor, which I disagree
with, and that somehow the world's going to
end.
But I've asked this question in letters to
Apple and Google in March of 2015.
I'm still waiting for the courtesy of a response.
And I think we need-if you're going to-if
we are going to measure, as we have to, what
is the risk of maintaining the ability to
open a phone by the company, what is the added
risk that that puts us in harm's way of, versus
what is the consequence to law enforcement
of not being able to access those phones.
I can tell you I have 230 cases in my office
from homicide to sex abuse to child abuse
to drugs to guns that I can't get into those
phones.
What is Apple telling me about how many times
a phone that was delivered by a law enforcement
agency to Apple as a result of their unlocking
the phone pursuant to court order that data
was ever compromised?
So I think we need an answer.
CHERTOFF: So I think, Gordon, there are two
types of encryption, and we have to be careful
not to confuse them.
The more general issue has to do with end-to-end
encryption, which has to do with when you're
either dealing with data in motion or data
at rest you encrypt it, except at the point
of initiation and the point of receipt.
And obviously there that's a critical element
in securing against people hacking into a
network and stealing your data, and relevant
to financial institutions, health care institutions,
et cetera.
Now, the issue that Cy is talking about is
a somewhat narrower issue that has to do deal
with a feature of the phone.
The encryption itself is very simple.
You're talking about four digits.
But it's designed to defeat efforts to repetitively
try different variations by slowing up the
time between each entry and ultimately stopping
anything further on the phone and wiping it
if you do it more than a certain number of
times.
That's really designed to deal with the problem
of somebody stealing your phone and then if
they didn't have that feature they could infinitely
go and try, you know, a number of combinations
and crack the phone, you know, relatively
easily.
The issue in Apple, which is technical-and
I should just disclose, we do work with Apple,
so it's out there-was whether creating a tool
that would allow you to basically substitute
out the operating system that currently exists
for a system that did not have that feature-namely
the one that shuts down the phone after you
have too many tries-whether that once it was
created would potentially get released and
compromise other phones.
At the end of the day, in a way, this is lawyers
call a moot point, because inevitably what
you're going to have going forward is a new
system that's configured in such a way so
as to be even more protective of the device
itself.
And if the U.S. government were to say it's
illegal to do that, I guarantee you, you would
be able to buy a phone that does that within
10 minutes on the dark web.
So again, I think in some cases, on the narrower
issue, the lifespan of what we've been fighting
about is very short.
The broader issue however is very, very important,
which is do we preserve the right to encrypt
data at rest or in motion within a network
and on the Internet.
VANCE: I got to disagree with my colleague,
because I don't think that's-I think that's
a framing of the issue, but I don't think
that's how it was framed for us by Apple.
Tim Cook said that were there to be, in his
words, a backdoor, which he means Apple maintaining
a key to open its device, he alluded it to
threatening millions of Apple consumers.
He likened it to causing cancer.
So it was very much about-if Apple maintains
a digital key, as it did up until September
2014, is that such a risk that we should forego
the ability to access those phones in the
service of causing cases and-cases for victims.
And for what increased level of security?
I simply don't think Apple has, as I indicated,
answered the question.
And, yes, there are many aspects of data in
transit.
That's very important.
But in terms of just accessing a phone, I'm
just not aware that there's ever been-
SEGAL: I think perhaps the answer is out there
in the sense that by 2014, or certainly if
not by now, there is nobody who can say we
can defend ourselves.
So even if we don't know that Apple has ever
been breached and that this tool has been
stolen, this general sense would be nobody
could ever say we can protect whatever it
is we created.
VANCE: But you have to measure-you have to
quantify it.
If you are going to say: We are taking a whole
body of evidence that is essential-that has
been essential for centuries, use of warrants
based upon probable cause, reasonable searches,
to get evidence to build cases against people
committing crimes, you have to quantify the
risk that results from this ability to unlock
your phone.
It's never been done.
Did it happen once?
Did it happen a thousand times?
Has it happened a hundred thousand times?
Right now, that number has never been put
on the table.
And until we quantify that number, you're
asking the entire United States, all of law
enforcement and all the public, to say it's
a crisis.
SEGAL: Well, plus the risk that Secretary
Chertoff said, that now with the golden age
of surveillance there are other ways of perhaps
breaking those keys.
So-
VANCE: Well, that's not a risk, that's-
SEGAL: Well, that's a mitigating factor.
So-
VANCE: You know, I've never met a victim yet-a
mother of a daughter who has been sexually
assaulted, a parent of a child that's been
murdered, a police officer investigating a
terrorisms case-who said to me, oh, I don't
really care if you get the conversation.
I just want to know the metadata.
Juries expect proof beyond a reasonable doubt.
And the content of communications is what
proves intent in a criminal case.
And it's not just being able to say that Cy
Vance emailed Mike Chertoff on Saturday morning.
That will get you so far.
But I'm pretty clear that that doesn't get
you where you-if it was personal to you, you
would want the government to be able to build
the evidence.
CHERTOFF: Yeah, so I guess I would say this.
Again, I totally understand that if your job
is to be a prosecutor you want every bit of
evidence you can get.
And that's why prosecutors don't want to suppress
evidence, have evidence suppressed when it's
gotten illegally, for example.
But let me tell you, I mean-use the example
I talked about earlier.
In the pre-smartphone days, when we had electronic
surveillance, and I did organized crime cases.
And the guys I investigated did not talk.
They used sign language or they walked around
the block.
And I remember convicting people of murder,
and I didn't have conversations.
What I did have was pictures of people walking
around the block-(laughter)-and records of
telephone call from point A to point B. And
somehow, you know, we were able to fumble
our way to getting those folks sentenced to
a hundred years in prison.
So I don't want to minimize the importance,
but to me it's not an all or nothing proposition
how you can do that.
VANCE: And those cases were likely built on
informants who took the stand and said: I
talked to Mickey.
Mickey told me to kill-
CHERTOFF: Actually not, but I won't bore you
with war stories.
(Laughter.)
CROVITZ: So we're about to go to the question
period.
And please wait for a microphone.
And the usual Council rules-stand up, identify
yourself, be brief in your question.
But before we get to questions, I just want
to take the presider's right here to observe
that the Democratic Party member represents
the law and order side of this panel.
(Laughter.)
Michael Chertoff, which has worked with Republican
administrations is opposing law enforcement's
request.
(Laughter.)
And yet another example for those of us from
New York that Washington is becoming increasingly
unpredictable.
(Laughter.)
CHERTOFF: Gordon, I-in all seriousness, Gordon,
I do want to make a point, which is to me
this is actually because a choice between
two types of security.
And I do think that the issue of being able
to have, particularly I'm not talking about
so much device encryption as end-to-end network
encryption, is really-like someone like all
you who transacts with banks online or does
other personal things online, or even has
personal emails that are sensitive that you
don't want to have out there-the ability to
have those encrypted is part of securing what's
valuable to me.
And since the government doesn't take the
responsibility, and shouldn't, of operating
and owning everything on my network, it's
on me to do it.
And all I want is the tools to carry it out.
CROVITZ: I think the first question is in
the front row.
Q: Amitai Etzioni, George Washington.
I wonder-
VANCE: I don't think your mic is on.
Q: OK.
Thank you.
I wonder if there's a whole other level of
discussion which I would love to learn about,
if these things are being decided on a completely
different level kind of politically.
People are afraid to touch Google and Apple.
They have strong lobbying.
They have libertarian ideologies to support
them.
So all these intellectual arguments, which
I cherish-and that's the way I spend my life-are
really not going to decide this issue.
And therefore, we hear these arguments which
don't stand a minimal examination-for instance,
the notion that if Americans cannot get Apple
phones they're going to take Chinese phones
and use them, and trust China not to have
a backdoor; or it doesn't matter if you're
going to be out of business for five years,
dark, because five years from now somebody
else will come up with a way to break encryptions.
None of these arguments hold a minimal exam.
But isn't that really not what's happening
here?
Isn't it just a political struggle, including
the fact the president was very reluctant
to speak to this issue?
CROVITZ: Who would like to take this question?
VANCE: Well, I'll just jump in.
I don't think it's just a political issue.
And I'm just speaking about myself personally.
You know, I am elected to be the head law
enforcement elected official for New York,
which is the number one-New York City-number
one terrorism target in the country.
I have some of the most serious crimes occurring
in my jurisdiction.
So this is not-neither academic nor political,
it's very practical.
And for folks like me around the country,
95 percent of the cases-criminal cases in
the country don't occur in federal courts,
they occur in state courts.
And so the biggest impact of inability to
access at the very least the content of the
devices themselves, putting aside for the
moment the data in transit, matters greatly.
And of course, what we're doing is talking
to political leaders, Senators and others,
to try to convince them, in my view, that
they should address this with federal legislation.
I think that has to be the solution.
And they need to do it quickly because I have
a-and I think we should all have-a sense of
urgency around this issue not being resolved.
So, respectfully, politics doesn't enter into
this for me at all.
And I think I represent a large percentage
of the law enforcement community that is trying
to wrestle with this.
CROVITZ: Just to rephrase the question a little
bit, and try to elicit another response, when
Apple announced its change to its operating
system in 2014, it posted on its website this
line, that said, it's not-it's no longer technically
feasible for us to respond to government warrants,
which I think may be one of the examples that
the FBI director used to say they were marketing
their inability even to respond to government
warrants.
So-
VANCE: Gordon, another screen had that same
phrase when they just-they came out with iOS
7 and said: Apple, unlike its competitors,
cannot open its devices.
So I think-
SEGAL: And we haven't said the word "Snowden"
yet.
I mean, I think we do have to realize that
there was a motivation from the companies
to create distance between them and the U.S.
government and all other governments.
So you know, I do think there was that framing
that was out there that we just can't ignore.
CROVITZ: In the back.
Q: Alan Raul, Sidley Austin, and former vice
chair of the Privacy and Civil Liberties Oversight
Board.
So your reframing of the prior question and
Adam's response really goes to my question,
which is: Would you address the kind of background
context of what the U.S. government can do
to address the concerns that were inflamed
by Snowden, and the sense of overreach in
the acquisition of data by the U.S. government,
which I don't think is a fair perception,
but it is the context?
And this panel was titled privacy and security,
and this debate.
And the privacy side is this perception that
too much data is being acquired by the U.S.
government, without justification.
Again, unfair, but without an effective rebuttal
by the Federal government, you know, by city
and state governments.
So what can be done to address that?
And perhaps, you know, the government needs
to look at some of the cases that it brings.
You know, there's pending before the 2nd Circuit
now the extraterritorial search warrant case,
right?
So that is an example, perhaps, of the U.S.
government overreaching into servers in other
countries that, again, gives rise to this
dynamic of creating distance between the companies
and the government.
And I think if you would address, what can
the government do to address that perhaps,
you know, mitigate the tension?
CHERTOFF: So let me take this first.
And you know, Alan here has two separate issues.
On the issue-the first issue you raised, I
think that really is what they call the 215
issue, or the metadata issue.
There is-and first of all, I mean, I have
nothing good to say about Snowden, nor do
I credit his version of what he put out there
as sort of being accurate.
But the sense got out there that government-because
the government collected and stored a lot
of metadata, which is literally phone number,
IP address, originating communication, the
address to which it went, and duration-not
even a name.
Which is kept so you can look for patterns,
if you have a predicate to do so.
You know, that treated as somehow a gross
violation of the law.
Now, the first answer is, when the government
finally belated declassified much of their
legal foundation for this, including opinions
written by the FISA Court, it became clear
that in fact this was comfortably within the
law, it didn't go outside the law.
And beyond that, that it was really minimal
intrusion into privacy.
And was essentially what a telephone billing
record has in the modern age.
And I think there was a failure to-a disappointing
failure on the part of the government to explain,
in fact, that this was pretty modest.
And there's enormous value to be gained by
doing this.
And I say this as somehow who in the days
after 9/11 had the responsibility to see who
the heck else was out there.
And you track that by looking at all these
metadata collections.
The second point you raised, though, which
is somewhat distinct, is a little bit related.
This has to do with the fact that the U.S.
government, when it seeks to get information,
data, about, let's say, a foreigner, who's
really in a foreign country, in a data center
that's in a foreign country, will go against
the service provider that's doing business
in the United States and say: Well, you have
to turn this over to us because we're going
to subpoena you.
And that's an issue we used to confront with
banks.
And the question is, is that subpoena like
asking for bank records, which we typically
allow the government to do?
Or is it like telling a U.S. branch of a Swiss
bank: You have to break into the safety deposit
box of somebody in Switzerland?
And we're not going to go to Swiss court.
We're going to go to a U.S. court.
That highlights the problem of a world in
which our law is still sovereign centric but
the data moves around the globe.
And the real answer is not to eliminate the
ability to get foreign evidence, but to find
a cooperative and efficient way to get multiple
sovereigns to agree on a process to do this
quickly, but that respects the sovereignty
of the country, for example, whose citizen
is involved.
So again, this is not about closing that off,
but it is about avoiding what happened in
Brazil, where a judge shut down WhatsApp in
Brazil because the judge ordered, I guess
it was Facebook, to turn over data in the
U.S., it violated U.S. law.
And the company said, well, what do I do?
And that's not a good situation to be in for
anybody.
SEGAL: But I mean, the impact of the Snowden
revelations was more than the metadata, right?
We have allegations that they undermined encryption,
that they hacked into Yahoo and Google servers,
that they were sitting on zero-days, that
they intercepted equipment and put implants
in it.
So I think the impact on the companies is
clearly much broader than the metadata.
And that has never been repaired.
VANCE: Right.
And I think it's an important point that what
caused this stir was federal action.
(Laughter.)
we, who are handling 95 percent of the criminal
cases in the country, are now trying to push
ahead to do our job when upset has been caused
that has nothing to do with us.
And we only get access to devices through
search warrants.
So again, obviously these are-they are overlapping
issues, but the Snowden revelations clearly
have, I think, had a big impact on public
opinion.
I understand clearly the relationship between
those revelations and the actions of the companies.
But if-looking at Apple-if iOS 7, up to September
2014 was as secure as they said it was, and
if we don't have any indication that there's
ever been a breach, at least of the data at
rest, by delivering a phone to them, what
is the problem Apple is trying to cure?
Is it a public relations problem or is it
a privacy problem?
And I think it may have been more a public
relations problem than a real privacy problem.
CROVITZ: Yes, ma'am.
Q: Thank you.
My name is Courtney Radsch.
And a couple of questions.
First, there were reports that when you gained-when
the FBI gained access to the phone, that the
reason that they lost access to it is because
they changed the password.
So I'd like to know if that's true or not,
because then that actually seems to be more
of an issue of governmental-you know, of failure
on the government's part, that they should
deal with not the tech company.
Also, given that we're at the Council on Foreign
Relations, I think it's a big ironic that
we're talking about this as if it's only a
U.S. problem, because the fact is that journalists
and activists around the world depend on encryption.
And so this does not happen in a United States
vacuum.
And with respect to the local law enforcement,
I think one of the things we've seen is the
militarization of local law enforcement and
the transition of not only of military equipment
but also intelligence equipment to local law
enforcement.
And so this is, you know, within a broader
lack of trust in either local or national
governments.
And when you see law enforcement abuses ranging
from, you know, Black Lives Matter and Ferguson,
up through mass surveillance of U.S. citizens,
I think it's hard for us to trust the government
to do what's right, and that there's a difference
between communication that occurs when people
feel that they're under surveillance as when
they feel that they're able to communicate
in private, especially when you're the member
of a minority group, Muslim, a journalist
and you have to think about source protection,
because that metadata can reveal the sources
of journalists.
CROVITZ: Several questions there.
VANCE: Well, Mike-
CHERTOFF: No, you go first.
(Laughter.)
VANCE: Great questions.
And many questions.
And no simple answers.
I think, first, what law enforcement needs
to do, and I think people in law enforcement
who are smart are, is to address these questions
directly.
I certainly try to do that, for example, on
the issue of race and criminal justice.
I think these are big issues and prosecutors
and police can't-we have to explain what we're
doing and why, and to answer some of your
questions.
There's a technical question with regard to
whether we lost the opportunity in San Bernardino
to access the phone.
Jim Comey has answered that question.
If I try to repeat what he said I'm sure I'm
going to get it wrong.
But I think there was-there was some apparent
confusion over getting access as a phone owned
by the county, and somehow that ended up having
the phone get locked up.
So that's number one.
And from the local law enforcement perspective,
I've never used a Stingray in our office,
which is the device that captures all sorts
of phones in the area.
Our investigators don't use it.
If they did use them, they'd be getting a
search warrant for them.
And you had a lot of other questions which
were just, it seems to me, based upon Americans
have lost trust-or, some Americans have lost
trust in law enforcement.
And I understand that.
And it is why, whether the issue is race and
criminal justice or the issue is talking about
how we need to adhere to constitutional standards
every time we are trying to get evidence through
court order, I think we have to do a better
job-not do a better job, but communicate about
what we're doing, because we should get your
trust back, if we can.
CROVITZ: Please.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Q: Hi.
Thank you.
My name is Brooke (sp), from Congressman Hurd's
office.
So I was wondering if you can comment on a
part of this debate which was sort of touched
on, and it has to do with the companies themselves.
So the backdoor debate aside, I was wondering
what is the legal precedent for forcing a
company to do something like create in every
case some sort of ability to open up encrypted
data, or, you know, if they can't because
they've created an encrypted phone that they
don't have the, quote, unquote, "key" for,
to force them to create the key for it?
And I had one more question, but I don't remember
it.
(Laughter.)
So I was wondering if you could comment on
that.
CHERTOFF: So I'll start on this one.
So I think there are a couple of issues.
There's a narrow issue in the case of San
Bernardino, which I guess has not been resolved
because it's moot, about whether in the context
of a search warrant-I mean, the All Writs
Act, which allows-basically what the judge
does is says, you know, I'm granting this
warrant.
And the authority to do anything-the company
has to do anything to effectuate the warrant
that is necessary.
So that's-so, for example, if you're a landlord
in a house and there's a search warrant, you
have to, you know, open the door.
The question that was raised, which has not
been resolved, is how far does that power
go?
Can you say to somebody: You have to write-spend
six months writing code to get around a problem?
Well, that sounds a little bit like you're
enlisting them against their will in the police.
The broader question is whether you could
require as a congressional matter, or pass
a law that would say you have to have the
capability with respect to any encrypted data
for the company or the host to be able to
get into that data.
I think, you know, if Congress passed that
law, it would probably be constitutional,
off the top of my head.
I think it would be very unwise, because,
again, if you understand the way encryption
works-and again, I'm talking not so much about
device encryption here but about end-to-end
encryption of data on a network.
In order to create the ability to do that,
you would either have to have a duplicate
key in possession of the company, which would
then become a target for being stolen, or
you'd have to build into the encryption a
flaw in the implementation, which is typically
the way we tend to crack encryption now, because
the fact of the matter is even people who
are trying to be perfect in encryption often
fail.
For example, they'll use the same prime number
twice or something.
And that radically reduces the amount of time
it takes to decrypt something.
So I think it's not so much a question in
the case of the broader issue of legal authority,
as to the question of the tradeoff between
your ability to get general encryption protection
versus the individual case.
And I know that in Congress now there's a
bill to have some kind of a digital commission
to look at this, which probably-I don't know
that these issues are well-resolved in one-off
cases.
And I say this as a former judge.
I don't know that judges are always the most
technologically astute and well-informed people.
(Laughter.)
Getting a group to look at this, who have
the technical background, might be illuminating,
actually.
VANCE: OK, I'll jump in.
CROVITZ: Please.
VANCE: Companies historically in America have
been asked to-or required to do many things
in order to address law enforcement imperatives.
So banks didn't volunteer to have to file
currency transaction reports when more than
$10,000 of cash is moved.
They have to file them because we found out
that drug dealers were moving cash through
banks.
The phone companies didn't volunteer to have
their-to make their lines accessible to law
enforcement if they had Title 3 warrants.
They had to, because everyone knew that bad
guys were using the phone to commit crimes
and it was necessary to talk to them.
So we aren't really, in my mind, in that different
a place today.
We know criminals are using smartphone devices
for criminal purposes.
There's a phone conversation-we actually have
a report from our office, which we'll make
available to anybody who wants it outside-where
there's a conversation of an inmate in Rikers
Island who's talking with his confederate
outside.
And the inmate is asking the confederate:
Did you make sure you got the iOS 8 devices?
Because the government can't get into them
and it's a gift from god.
So the criminals have figured this out.
So the question is, is Apple really any different
than the banks, and all the money laundering
regulations they have to follow and report
on and documents that they have to keep?
Or is it that different from the phone companies
who have to provide access that require them
to set up a connect-something probably requiring
software development as well as a physical
location?
And I think the answer is, not really.
SEGAL: I think that there is a difference
in the sense, to the earlier question about
our other foreign policy goals of protecting
dissidents and journalists and others in other
places.
So we're going to have a situation where you
can imagine, where the companies are going
to be forced by numerous governments to do
this issue.
And then the question is, who are they going
to say no to, right?
So are they going to say, well, we've agreed
to do this for the United States.
We've agreed to do it for India.
We'll do it for Germany.
We're not going to do it for China.
Maybe we'll do it-you know, so then I think
the situation becomes slightly different.
Financial sector, we've had agreement basically-it's
been able-we've been more able to shape norms
on antiterrorism and criminal-kind of a shard
interest there.
On the free speech issue, we're going to face
a fundamental division that we're not going
to be able to resolve.
VANCE: Let's test that.
Let's look at China.
Let's look at the request China made to Apple
for information on Apple accounts before iOS
8 and after.
So before iOS 8, between July and December
of 2014, China made 31 requests to Apple for
account data out of 39 accounts.
And Apple provided in response to the Chinese
request 32 percent of the time, OK?
Between January and June of 2015, the next
six months, now this is after iOS 8 has come
in, China made 24 requests for 85 accounts,
and Apple responded to 29 percent of those
requests.
And these are-Apple describes this as the
equivalent of a search warrant.
And then July to December 2015, 32 requests
out many thousands of accounts which I think
relates to a phishing investigation-there
was a lot of phishing going on-P-F-fishing.
And so Apple responded to 53 percent.
So my point is that we have data from Apple
that suggests that when Apple went to full-disk
encryption, it really wasn't that different
from when Apple had access-when Apple had
access through iOS 7 in response to government
search warrants.
So my point is that this was happening before.
It's happened after the switchover.
And so when we are told that the world's going
to end, and that if China's going to use this
power thousands of times, I'm not sure the
data supports it from Apple.
CHERTOFF: Yeah, I'm not sure-there's a bit
of a difference, just to be clear, about the
issue that was presented in the Apple case,
which was getting onto the device, versus
the data which had been uploaded to the cloud.
My recollection from the press reporting in
San Bernardino was actually any of the data
that was backed up to the cloud was furnished
to the FBI.
And the reason they had a problem at the end
was that somebody by altering the password
stopped the automatic backup system.
So it's not been the case, as I understand
it, that the company says: If we have unencrypted
data we will refuse to turn it over.
I think they agree they have to.
It's do they need to forebear from having
a system which they don't have access to because
if they don't have access to it they will
not be able to comply.
And that's really what the issue is about.
SEGAL: And all Apple user data has to be stored
in China.
So they may have just simply turned over the
data that they had.
CHERTOFF: Right.
Yeah.
VANCE: Does it have to be stored in China?
Or is that an accommodation?
CHERTOFF: Well, I think that's the condition
as Chinese data.
And that gets us to the point that Alan raised
earlier, which is you have to reconcile the
fact that you have multiple sovereigns and
you have global data.
So it would be one thing if- and maybe a condition
of entry into a particular marketplace, you
can debate whether you should obey it or not,
is that the data generated in that particular
country needs to be held there.
It would be quite something else if the Chinese
requested data of an American held in the
U.S., and that were turned over without appropriate
process.
And that gets us exactly to the issue Alan
raised about how do you reconcile these conflicting
jurisdictional issues.
CROVITZ: Please.
Q: Henry Farrell at George Washington University.
Just building on all of that, does U.S. law
enforcement pay attention to these questions
that Adam raised about possible demonstration
effects, setting precedents, creating weaknesses
that might be exploited by less sort of careful
actors in the world than the U.S.?
And should it pay attention to these questions,
or is that outside of its mandate?
VANCE: Well, I think, from my perspective,
the questions are very big ones.
And what I have found-what I disagree with
is this point, and its following on your question:
Other companies historically have had to adjust
when it was clear that the product they were
selling and using was being used by criminals
and it was a real problem.
Apple's response, for a variety of reasons,
was to essentially cut off access to the data
in the devices themselves.
And it did so using its own-it made its decision.
The consequences of that, however, are broad.
And they will touch all jurisdictions of the
United States.
And they will impact the victims in cases
all over the United States.
And when something that big happens, my question
is: Who gets to decide where the line should
be drawn between privacy and public safety?
Should it be two companies whose operating
systems run 96.7 percent of the world's smartphone
market?
I'm not worried about Apple running out of
money.
I'm not worried about Apple losing market
share.
They own it.
These are two phenomenally wealthy companies,
and they decided we're going to draw the line
of public safety and privacy over here.
I really don't think they get to do that.
I think Congress gets to do that.
And that's why I believe there should be a
political and legislative discussion about
this, probably.
Our cases in court have to move according
to timetables set by statute.
Statute of limitations are starting to run-can
run on cases that are very important.
We don't have the luxury, particularly at
state court, of tons of time.
And that's the reality of how this is playing
out in our state courts.
And it's a reality that if you're a victim,
it impacts you.
CROVITZ: So I'm going to take the privilege
of the presider by asking the last question
of the evening, which is, you know, the Senate
Intelligence Committee, in a bipartisan manner,
introduced a draft bill that would require
technology companies essentially to make-to
be able to respond to requests for information,
much like phone companies, telecom companies
have had to for many years.
And in that bill, at the beginning, it says
no entity is above the law, reflecting some
of the views that Cy Vance has made here.
My question is, there's also legislation in
France and in Britain.
Of the three countries-France, Britain, United
States-which one is likeliest to pass the
law first?
(Laughter.)
Or maybe I should say last.
VANCE: Well, I think they're likely to pass
it before we do.
The presidents of each of those countries
have been very outspoken in their-in their
need to take on this issue of encryption.
I don't know when it will happen.
But I think it actually may help America sort
itself out in this process, because if the
French and the British create laws which address
this issue of what can and cannot be encrypted,
that I think will have an impact on American
legislators, and I think may give them, I
hope, comfort that they can pass legislation
without fear that the world's going end.
CHERTOFF: So, Gordon, let me ask this question,
because this is, as I said earlier, not just
about getting to a particular phone.
If you passed a bill like that, what would
happen to WhatsApp?
You know, disappearing messages.
That would become illegal, because if the
message isn't stored, if it disappears as
soon as you read it, you can't produce it.
So now what you're really doing is you're
basically making it illegal almost to destroy
any communication.
Maybe it should be impossible to delete your
email.
Maybe there should be a rule that you can
never shred a piece of paper.
I mean, we don't generally operate in this
country on the assumption that you have to
organize your life so that in the event somebody
wants to subpoena you or investigate you to
make it easy.
In fact, I can make it easier still.
Let's have a law that says this has to be
on all the time, has to record everything
that I say and video and audio.
And then if I do something wrong it'll be
really easy.
It would have made my job very much easier
when I was a prosecutor.
I think, you know, the phone, to me, is a
small subset of a larger issue.
And that's why I said earlier I do think-I
agree with Cy, it is worthy of study.
It shouldn't be decided by the happenstance
of a particular case.
But I do think we need to understand that
there's a broad implication of this beyond
just the particular configuration of a particular
phone.
VANCE: And I think there are actually ways
to go forward on this.
Right now we have two sides who really are
on opposites-polar opposites.
And there isn't-there really doesn't seem
to be a public discussion about how can we
move forward?
Imagine a world in which there were different
levels of encryption.
There might be one level of encryption for
communications and content, and another level
of encryption when it dealt with autonomous
moving vehicles that-self-driving vehicles.
That second group is something that obviously-if
that's captured, that's immediately dangerous.
By content and communications may be different.
There's a-we should really sit down and we
should explore whether it is in fact true-and
I think part of the problem is that Apple
in particular has said hell no, no way, no
time, no how.
And I don't think that's helpful to anybody
in resolving this, although I respect their
ingenuity and the passion of their beliefs.
It's not helping us figure this out.
SEGAL: I suspect we won't have the luxury
of having that rational debate.
I don't think we can discount the role that
fear has played in all of these discussions.
And so you can imagine, you know, an event
that happens here or in France or in Britain
that would totally shift the debate.
And people will rush to make a law so this
won't happen again, even though the law will
not be effective.
VANCE: And if that happens, that law is going
to look a lot worse for Apple and Google than
the law that we could perhaps move forward
to if we sat at the table and sorted this
out.
CROVITZ: And in the meantime, the Council
on Foreign Relations, always trying to do
its bit for the world, Mike Chertoff has dictated
a Chinese statute requiring Chinese statute
requiring Chinese citizens to keep their phones
on.
It's a fantastic idea.
(Laughter.)
So please thank the panel in the customary
way.
(Applause.)
(END)